[audience applauds]
[audience cheers]
[gunshot blasts]
Ken Bombace: That's part of our job.
What I don't like is that he
pulls his weapon immediately.
He would probably be the
person tackled if he did that.
Hi, my name is Ken Bombace,
and I have over 20 years of
law-enforcement experience.
I've led a company as the CEO
of Global Threat Solutions,
which is a protection firm that provides
comprehensive protection
services to executives,
people of high net worth, and celebrities.
And today I'm gonna be
reviewing movie and TV clips
of bodyguard scenes and
rating them for realism.
Creasy: Pita, you have a pencil?
Ken: You're never going to be distracted.
You don't text. You don't make calls.
You're definitely not gonna
be writing something down
while you're driving a client.
Protection agents will
have what we call a go bag,
a tactical bag, a go bag,
and you're gonna have
everything you need in there.
You'll even put some
food, drinks in there.
You might have to sit in
that vehicle for hours.
To do your job, you'd have a flashlight.
You have your laptop with you.
You're gonna have your phone, chargers,
backup battery chargers.
Something to write with, pens
if you have to take notes
when your principal's
giving you some instructions
or maybe a staff member.
These are just some of the things that
you might have with you at any time.
[dog barks]
And might a protection agent be tasked
with watching the principal's dog
while they're in a meeting or something?
Sure, it does happen.
Creasy: Run! [gunshot blasts]
Ken: You definitely
don't fire warning shots
in a situation like this.
I understand it's part of the storyline,
but that's something we don't do.
Your mission, and this
applies to every clip
that I'll talk about, in
any protection operation
is to get the principal
off "the X," we call it.
The X being the location of danger,
the immediate vicinity of danger.
Our job is to get them out of there
as fast as we can, and that's it.
[gunshots blast]
Firefights and shoot-outs,
whether in the military or in police,
are chaotic and confusing.
When I was in the military,
obviously I was involved in firefights
when I was in Iraq as an army officer.
I think they did a pretty good job
at depicting a shoot-out like that.
For the circumstances he
had, with a one-man detail,
he did the best he
could in that situation.
Creasy: Pita! Run! [gunshot blasts]
Ken: Some training goes
in on their side too,
meaning the principal.
So, code words, yes, that happens.
It can be, maybe you see something
that's suspicious that they don't know.
So you would use a word
rather than just say,
"Hey, watch out. There's a threat."
I would give it a seven.
[crowd cheering]
Bodyguard: Ma'am, excuse
me, if you don't mind,
I suggest we keep moving.
Bodyguard: Ma'am, let's go. Let's go.
Ken: I've done a celebrity
detail for a big award show,
and when my principal exited the vehicle,
he decided to run about a
half a mile down a street
crowded with fans and
slapping all of their hands,
and I had to run right alongside of him.
There was no telling him not to.
♪ La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la. ♪
Ken: They're not gonna be in a room where
the celebrity is actually getting changed,
but rehearsing, prepping in a green room,
absolutely, it's very
likely you would have
a protection agent in there.
Bryan: Excuse me, miss.
I know this isn't the right time,
but I have a daughter
who wants to be a singer,
and I was wondering if
you had any tips for her.
Ken: As the CEO of a protection firm,
that is what I refer to
as a fireable offense.
You do not,
as your celebrity client
is about to head onstage,
stop her in front of a
group of all of her staff
and ask her for a personal favor
or a personal opinion.
That is something we do not do.
Totally unprofessional.
Bodyguard: Waiting on an airstrike.
And we're waiting, and we're waiting.
[Bryan's phone rings]
Bryan: Hello.
Ken: They may not be assigned
to go out into the crowd,
but that does not mean
you're playing cards
in the back room.
You need to be right backstage
monitoring everything,
not playing cards.
[dramatic music]
That part right there, I would
say, is pretty realistic.
She exits the stage,
there's chaos obviously,
this is a large venue, big concert.
There's venue security and venue staff
that you have no control over there.
So, sure, that can happen.
What do they do? They move her quickly
and professionally out of there.
Bryan: It's OK. It's OK. You're safe now.
Ken: You know, they're
human, and you're human.
As long as you're doing your job,
you could obviously support them
to make them feel better
during this tough time.
I've had scenarios where principals
are emotional and upset over something
that happens, or afraid, quite frankly.
And they do show their appreciation.
You would just wanna guard against
keeping boundaries up.
You don't want to get too
close in this industry,
so you maintain a certain
level of professionalism.
I would expect him after that interaction
to let me know about it, that it happened.
I'll give it a six.
[Cookie screaming]
[punching]
Cookie: Yeah, yeah!
I think the fight scene
was pretty unrealistic.
They're having a fistfight in the street,
but then another subject
who was the driver
or someone else is assisting
and kicking the person on the ground.
Could there be untrained people
that call themselves bodyguards
that do that sort of thing? Sure.
Malcolm: You know, this
is a bad neighborhood.
Cookie: Aw, you worried
about me? I'm fine.
Ken: It does happen, where
people can be inebriated.
They can be belligerent.
You have to remember this person is,
all intents and purposes,
your boss, the principal.
So you may rely on staff members
that you work closely with,
non-security people who
work closely with them,
or even family members to intervene.
You also wanna protect them against
things like embarrassment.
There's a famous scene
where somebody popped out
and hit Bill Gates in the face with a pie.
That is a tragic fail
for a protection team
for that to have been able to happen.
Was he assassinated? No.
But was he embarrassed?
Was he not happy with that scenario?
Is that a liability to him
as a businessman? Sure.
Cookie: Lucious, Lucious, Lucious.
Malcolm: Are you OK with
the way he looks at you?
Whatever that is, that's too intense.
Ken: Of course, it could happen.
Yeah, you can't leave them
during a situation where
they could get hurt
or they're vulnerable, of course.
So, yes, might you physically have to?
You would, if that's the scenario.
And people, you know,
principals are people too.
Malcolm: I've done a thorough review
of both your home and your
corporate headquarters.
Lucious: Really?
Ken: Yes, a comprehensive assessment
on an estate or residence
and the corporate facility,
of course we would do that.
But what I would say is
you would not do it most likely
without the principals knowing
about it and assisting,
because you wouldn't have access
to everything that you'd need
to really do a comprehensive
security assessment.
That part of it, where
he sort of surprised him
with it, saying, "I've already done it,"
there's only so far you can go.
Might you in a certain scenario
use your body to tackle
or at least shield your principal?
Sure, that can happen
if there's a great enough threat to them.
Would you do it in this
scenario? Probably not.
It's an unrealistic
scenario to begin with,
but you would probably not do it.
It might be the last
time you worked for them.
It's a thinking person's game.
This is not a brute-force game.
You need people with an intellect.
You need people who can
think on their feet,
maintain calm when things get hectic.
And that could be not necessarily
an immediate threat to your principal.
You have developed an entire
itinerary for the day.
You've done advanced site visits.
And in a moment's notice they
say, "We changed our mind.
Now we're going here, to another state."
Those are the things, you
have to be able to adapt
and continue seamlessly with your mission.
It takes a certain type of person
to be able to do this work.
You cannot panic easily.
You need to be able to
maintain calm at all times.
Do we have some people in this industry
who are 275 pounds and 6-foot-4? Sure.
Is that the norm? Absolutely not.
You do want someone who's physically fit,
who has a good appearance
that they can do this job.
Aesthetics are important,
especially for many principals,
but we do not need somebody
who's a bodybuilder,
who's a mixed-martial-arts
fighter, necessarily,
to do this job.
That's a one. I don't like zeros.
You would want to know as
much about them as possible.
She even reviewed her social media
for anything she might need to know
about her lifestyle or any concerns,
but also it goes so much deeper than that.
We have an onboarding process, really,
where you're gonna wanna
know their blood type,
you're gonna wanna know if they have
any medical conditions or allergies.
In the modern era,
you can find out a lot about people
just from open-source intelligence,
just by using the internet
and doing open-source searches.
Zoe: Who do you think you are? My mom?
Ken: Would you stand around
looking like a security agent
in the corner of the bar
watching them or in close proximity?
No.
A lot of times what you would do
is go sit at the bar or
go sit at your own table,
act like you're eating, have a drink,
maybe a nonalcoholic drink,
and keep an eye on them, while looking,
it's something we would
call covert protection.
So you don't wanna be overt.
Pretty realistic in every aspect.
I'm gonna give it an eight.
Executive protection agents don't have
hidden exotic-weapon vaults
that they use to choose
their weapons for the day.
They definitely don't choose
dual silenced pistols.
And they also don't
grab them by the trigger
when they pull them out of that vault,
which is something we learn
day one in the military
or in the police service,
is that, they call it "TF out of TG."
Keep your trigger finger
out of your trigger guard.
And he violates every one of those rules.
Sometimes we travel in motorcades,
more than one vehicle, of course,
lead and follow vehicles if
the threat's high enough,
depending on the size of your detail.
They depart and arrive together, however.
They don't join the principal's vehicle
at high speeds and in
very close proximity.
Michael: Get the engines started.
I want an immediate takeoff.
Airspace has already been cleared.
Pilot: Roger that.
Ken: We definitely do
not have the authority
to clear airspace
in the private-protection industry.
I've never heard of that happening.
Sometimes clients will
wait a considerable time
on the tarmac before departure.
We do a lot of work in Los
Angeles and in New York.
They will use what we call FBOs.
Those are the private air terminals.
They will use those at major airports,
but oftentimes their FBOs that that we use
are in smaller regional airports
close to major airports.
You probably would not
roll out the blue carpet
and have a ceremony on the tarmac
as you're getting them into the aircraft.
It would probably be a covert departure.
Bodyguard: Nothing for
miles, chief. Almost boring.
Michael: And what's our motto?
Bodyguards: Boring is always best.
Ken: You would definitely not line up
all of your detailed
vehicles in this manner,
having everybody stand there.
This is something I've never seen.
I can guarantee you they wouldn't have
their private-security helicopter
hovering over the runway too.
That would not be allowed.
[woman screaming]
Bodyguard: Bravo one down.
We need a cleanup team in here now!
Ken: They mentioned, "Get
the cleanup team in here."
We don't have cleanup teams
for when principals are assassinated.
The only cleanup team you're
gonna need is for your career,
because it's probably gonna be over
if something like this happens.
We have people visit every location.
They're gonna go days in advance,
meet with points of contact,
plan what route they're gonna take
in and out of that building.
We have to plan safe houses.
We have to know the closest
Level I trauma center
in case there is an incident like this
where someone gets shot or hurt.
We have to have safe houses,
which might be a police station close by
or someplace we know we can bring
the principal if there's a problem.
There's contingencies for everything.
But I can tell you,
assassinations like this in
principals, extremely rare.
I would say, I would give it a one
just because I don't
wanna give anybody a zero.
Donovan: In a populated
place, a department store,
I always walk ahead of you.
I don't like more than
five people between us,
so if you ditch me
because my back is to you,
that would be too far.
Ken: We don't walk in
front of the principal.
You don't do that because
you can't see them.
If you're a one-man detail,
like he is in this scenario,
protocol would say
usually to the rear right,
just offset, not directly behind them,
but offset to the rear right.
Now, they approach a door.
Are you gonna just step out in front
and maybe get that door for them?
Sure. You can do that.
You have visual all the time,
and you're staying in close proximity.
Might you have a principal that tells you,
"Don't get the door for me.
I don't like people getting doors for me"?
Yeah, I've had that too.
So it all depends on
the preference of them,
but you're definitely not
gonna walk in front of them,
because you know what happens?
You turn around and they're gone.
Donovan: At the risk
of being ungentlemanly,
I can't carry bags. My hands
always have to be free.
Ken: People do get bags here and there.
Are we used to exclusively do that,
and we're loading their packages
and not watching them and
jeopardizing security?
No, we're not. Do you help your principal
when you're getting them into a car,
put a bag in the trunk
and take that for them?
This is a customer-service-based business.
Hogan: What is it that
you look for exactly?
Ken: Before he decides he's
gonna walk out and chat with her
and tell her a little
bit about what he does,
you see he glances over
to the dressing room area.
As far as I could see in the scene,
she's the only one there.
He feels comfortable.
Donovan: The guy in the coat.
Hogan: What about him?
Donovan: Beats me. Why
is he wearing a coat?
Hogan: I don't know.
Donovan: I don't know either.
Ken: There's two kinds of
things I'd be looking for.
One of them would be someone who has
an unnatural interest in my principal.
They're watching them.
They seem to be in every store they're in.
That would raise alarms for me.
Also, there could be a threat by somebody
just in regular life, anyplace.
That threat might not even know
who your principal is or
that you're even there.
But sometimes things happen in
public where somebody could,
maybe there's fights that could break out
or maybe there's somebody who's
an emotionally disturbed
person visibly, you can see.
Those are things you would
want to keep an eye on.
We have a rigorous training program
for our agents to conduct
protection operations.
I would also add that there's
only so much you can do
in training for observation skills.
Some people have innate,
really well, inherent
observation skills, but it
is also a learned skill.
It's something you have to put time into
and discipline, and you can learn it.
I would probably give that
first scene maybe a four.
But the second scene, I like.
I think it's pretty realistic, actually.
So I'm gonna give that one an eight.
Budd: Go, go!
[gunshot blasts]
Stay down! The bullets
can pierce the windows,
but they can't get
through the armored metal.
Control. Sierra Zulu seven nine,
status zero, Thornton Circus.
Ken: He's maintaining calm.
He's maintaining radio communications
to make sure he gets help
there as quickly as possible.
That's the first thing to do.
And he's trying to keep her calm
and guide her in what to do.
They have a high-powered
rifle that went through
the ballistic glass but
won't go through the armor.
So he has to stay down,
she has to stay down
to try and maintain safety.
[gunshot blasts]
Would I exit that armored vehicle
not knowing exactly where
the threat is out there
to accommodate that
and maybe get a picture
with my phone to try and find them? No.
That part I think is unrealistic.
[Budd groaning]
[car engine starts]
That other agent, they make it very clear,
it's what we call a
DOA, or dead on arrival.
That person is not someone
who needs medical attention.
You might want to climb
right on top of them
to get that vehicle out of there.
This is a dire situation.
[tires screeching]
Performance driving is being able to do
one of those J-turns,
which is a fancy way for
turning around very quickly
and just being able to drive
at a high rate of speed in reverse.
It's not that easy.
So these are things
that you would train in.
That's an armored vehicle.
They have special training,
which I've been to.
And my agents, many of them have been to.
To drive armored vehicles,
they're much heavier
than a regular vehicle.
They handle much differently.
They stop slower. They accelerate slower.
Budd: Take care of the P.
Officer: Sarge.
Ken: So, he gets off the X. I like that.
When he stops, he has his
follow vehicle with him.
I like that.
That's where the realism stops.
The problem with law-enforcement officers,
if there is one, using this type of work,
is that it's very different
law-enforcement work.
Someone has a gun, there's a bad guy,
somebody who's shooting
people, you go towards them.
But in protection work,
that's not your problem.
I'd give it an eight.
[crowd cheering]
[gunshot blasts]
That's part of our job,
to take a shot for a client, a principal.
What I don't like is that
he pulls his weapon immediately.
He spots this person that
he identifies as a threat.
Nobody else has.
He would probably be the
person tackled if he did that.
I could tell you, in these awards,
and I've done security at many of them,
there's no weapons allowed.
Even off-duty police officers
who are now hired to
do protection services,
at these venues,
they're not even allowed
to bring weapons in.
Nobody gets weapons in.
That's the idea. It's a
weapons-free environment.
What we do is
heighten sense of observation, obviously,
because it's a big crowd.
The good news is
at those large award shows like that,
not just anybody could get in there.
They're vetted.
People are on a guest's
list with credentials.
I've worked those lines
checking those credentials
for people to get in.
With that being said, just
like in this scenario,
can somebody get press
credentials? Perhaps.
I mean, it doesn't take
much to get them nowadays.
And I've seen that, where
someone with press credentials
has gotten into a green room at an event
they shouldn't have been at.
They weren't a legitimate journalist.
Everybody probably has their own security.
They don't get to bring them in
and sit at their table with them.
Those people at most would be backstage,
waiting and observing. It's a rotation.
As the celebrities come out,
their security person waits
and then escorts them back out
to their green room or
wherever they're going to exit.
Also sometimes I've been at events
when they hired one company
to do all the security for these people.
So you would have,
though, someone assigned
to specifically escorting
them back and forth,
all of these people, to
wherever they're going,
till they get to their
own exit or security team.
My firm was hired at one point to do
large-scale political event
with multiple presidential candidates.
And I had to provide probably 40 agents,
because we would have someone assigned
to each one of those candidates
the entire time they were there.
I'll give it a six.
Moira: I want to introduce
you to someone, John Diggle.
He'll be accompanying you from now on.
Oliver: I don't need a babysitter.
Ken: Having clients that oppose
having protection services
or they have it against their will
is something that definitely happens.
John: I don't want there to
be any confusion, Mr. Queen.
My ability to keep you from harm
will outweigh your comfort.
Do we have an agreement?
Ken: You don't talk to
a principal that way
that he does, where
you call all the shots.
I like to point this out, where ultimately
the client really does
make the final decisions,
even with the president
of the United States.
Oliver: Got your eyes open?
John: That's what I'm here for, sir.
That and answering patronizing questions.
Ken: They don't want you
following them around
with an earpiece on and making it
very high profile that they have security.
You might sit in the corner of the room
and just observe things.
[gunshot blasts]
[crowd yelling]
John: I have to get you out of here.
Oliver: No, them.
Them.
Ken: You're always gonna watch the people
in close proximity to your principal.
You're gonna see if anyone
has an unnatural focus
or level of attention on your principal.
You're gonna watch for things,
anything that might be suspicious
or seem like somebody could
be unstable or dangerous.
And anytime they interact with someone,
you're gonna just keep an eye on that.
You're not gonna hover over
there around their back
and ready to attack anyone at any time.
It's unrealistic.
This is not a high realism rating,
no, for multiple reasons.
I would give it a two.